Bridge: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
So today we have the pleasure
of having
three gentlemen here
who have the experience
of actually working with O3D.
So they can provide
all of you with a bit
of their perspective
on what it's like
actually working with O3D,
so that you can go back
and use that experience
in terms of thinking
about building applications
on your own.
So to introduce myself,
I'm Henry Bridge.
I am the product manager
for O3D.
And why don't we get started
with a round of introductions?
McRae: Hello.
Okay.
My name is Brian McRae.
I am the founder
and director
of Crazy Pixel Productions.
We developed the Island demo.
I don't know if you've seen
that or not.
And we're also working on
a couple other projects
with Henry and his team
at Google.
Tinney: Hi.
My name is Wade Tinney.
I'm the CEO
of Large Animal Games.
We're an independent game
developer out of New York City
and we developed the
"Infinite Journey" game demo
that was featured
at the Sandbox yesterday.
Paradiso: Hey,
My name's Bob Paradiso,
and I was the lead programmer
on that game.
Bridge: Okay, great,
so thank you.
So I think--
I think why don't we start out
and show actually,
in case people haven't
seen it,
the semi-famous Beach demo
that we have
that Crazy Pixel Productions
developed for us.
Let's see.
I don't think
we're getting sound.
Ah, there we go.
man: This demo shows
the potential
of rendering high-quality
3-D graphics in the browser.
Notice the smooth
hardware-accelerated rendering
and detailed textures.
O3D supports advanced graphics
techniques.
For example, look at the
reflection on the water.
You can edit the code
for O3D applications
and see changes in real time.
In this demo, use the arrow keys
and the mouse to explore.
You can also press "H" to get
additional options
such as removing demo elements.
To learn more
and download O3D,
visit code.google.com/apis/o3d.
Bridge: All right, great.
So basically the genesis
of that is we had
sort of a pretty loose idea
of what we wanted
to showcase in terms
of the graphics possibilities
that you could actually
implement and render with O3D.
But really at the start
it was just that
and O3D hadn't even
been released.
So I was hoping, Brian,
you could
give us a little bit of an idea
of what attracted you
to working on O3D initially,
and also
since a lot of the audience
members here, I think,
maybe haven't worked on
3-D graphics projects before,
what the best way is to
interface with an art studio
such as yourself.
McRae: Yeah, well, my studio is
primarily a game developer.
We do, you know,
next-gen games.
But I love 3-D graphics.
I always have, and when Henry
and his team approached us
to do this demo, you know,
we jumped at the chance
to create something,
you know,
fun and exciting and
groundbreaking here with them.
So they showed us all these
really awesome, you know,
concepts and, you know,
island images and whatnot
and we, you know--
we got right to work
on creating this demo.
And, you know,
typically what you do when
you're creating something
like this is, you know,
lay everything out first.
Get the environment
sort of laid out in 3-D.
You know, you want
to do something
that's a little bit
more low-res
just so you can kind of
get the, you know,
proportions
and everything right.
We had two artists
working on it.
One artist was laying
in the environment.
The other one was doing
all the props.
And the goal that we had
with Google here
was let's really
push the graphics.
Let's see if we could get
a next-gen look.
So it was imperative that
we used, you know, normal maps,
diffuse maps, specular maps.
Just throw everything
that we can at it.
When we were working
on the actual terrain itself,
we used a middleware game engine
called Unreal
to kind of act as, like,
a bar on how far
Henry and his team could take
the materials and the shaders.
So we not only produced
everything in the Island demo
inside of 3D Studio MAX,
but we also created
a level inside of Unreal.
And we delivered
both of those
and then Henry
and his team were able
to, you know,
extract the shaders
and come up
with the pipeline that they
currently have
with their exporter.
But, yeah, we wanted to really
blend the materials,
you know, the textures and
that kind of thing
using, you know,
vertex, alpha, you know,
light maps to do the lighting.
You know,
just throw everything--
like, three kitchen sinks
at this thing
to really see how far
we could take it.
As far as working
with a 3-D studio,
it's a good idea to know exactly
what you're looking for
for your end result.
And it's also good
to have some assets
to just kind of play with
when you're getting started.
Sometimes, you know,
in the early phases,
you're not gonna need,
you know--
Say you wanted to do something
with a character,
you might not need, like,
a fully,
you know, articulated
character just to kind of
get your prototype
off the ground.
You might want to start
with something just
far more simple.
Like just a box or something.
Get that translating.
Get that moving around.
You know, have it feel right
before, you know,
spending the money and spending
the time and everything
getting all the 3-D,
because 3-D does, you know,
take a lot of time to produce
and to get it right.
So, yeah, I would definitely
recommend, like,
a two-phase approach,
you know?
Start with some, you know,
low-res objects,
lay everything in, and then,
you know, approach--
If you don't have the
capabilities yourself
at your studio,
approach a 3-D studio
and, you know, really have,
you know,
some samples of what you'd
like to see.
If you could hire
a concept artist
or if the 3-D studio has
a concept team available,
you know, work that out.
Figure out what you want
for the environments.
for the characters,
if that's where you're going.
If it's something far more,
I guess, abstract,
you know, have those ideas
and everything too
and the 3-D studios,
such as Crazy Pixel,
would be able to guide you as
far as how much it would cost,
how long it would take,
and so on.
I would expect for timelines,
if you wanted
a fully articulated character,
expect about two weeks or so
for that to be complete.
And in an environment
like this,
this was about one month time
for two artists to create.
Bridge: Okay, great.
Thank you, Brian.
So let's also--
Let's talk about
Large Animal also
and your project.
Let me get up.
So maybe, Wade,
you can also talk about
sort of what attracted you
to working on this
and what sort
of the basic ideas
were around
"Infinite Journey,"
which I hope if some of you got
the chance to come by
the client pod yesterday,
you got to see
both of these applications.
Okay, I'll turn
the volume down.
Oh.
Our buffering didn't work
so well.
Tinney: I can talk over it.
Yeah, so, um--
So we're--
We've been around
for quite some time--
about eight years--
and we've gone through
a couple of phases
as a company,
and about the last 18 months
we've been focused
on social network games--
so games that are integrated
into Facebook
and various OpenSocial
containers.
Prior to that, we were doing
PC downloadable games.
So we were working with, like,
the Torque game engine
and other game engines
and doing 3-D work.
So O3D, for us,
represented an opportunity
to kind of combine
our expertise
in doing higher-end PC games
and 3-D there
with the web-based content
that we're
most interested in right now.
So--and really kind
of deliver what we see
as the next generation
of social network games.
So--are we just
letting that buffer?
Bridge: Yeah.
Tinney: Okay.
So "Infinite Journey" wa--
The idea with
"Infinite Journey"
is that, you know,
it's a platformer,
but the idea is that ultimately
it will be integrated
into social networks
and all of the levels
in this platformer
will be levels
that are owned and were designed
and customized
by friends of yours
on the social network.
So as you're moving through,
you are having
this infinite journey, right?
Because every day another
friend may have
adjusted their level
or added a new level
and we're kind of stringing
those levels together.
And we can also, of course,
take you from one level
to one that's been designed
by someone else
who maybe likes
the same music as you
or has some other--
is in your network
in some other way
even if you don't have
a direct friend relationship.
So we have--
We worked on it
for about five weeks.
It was a team of four
and one intern.
Bob was the lead programmer.
Then we had a lead artist
who was doing concept work
and textures and UI design.
And then we had
a full-time 3-D artist
doing models
and applying those textures,
working in Maya.
And a full-time producer,
game designer,
and Bob as the engineer.
So--
Bridge: All right,
that's finished buffering.
Yes.
Tinney: So the gameplay
is pretty simple.
It's a platformer very much
like, you know,
"Super Mario" or any number
of other platformers.
What you're doing in the game
is you're collecting seeds.
And there's a little readout
that you can't see
in this video,
but you're collecting seeds
and then you're
planting flowers.
You can plant wherever
there's green.
And in order to beat each level,
you need to plant a certain--
a requisite
number of flowers.
And then this shows the portal
that you're unlocking
once you've planted
that number of flowers.
So you have--
we have one enemy
in this demo,
which is the runkin,
which is this kind of little
boulder guy who runs around
and he eats the flowers that
you've planted.
So he--
From a gameplay perspective,
he provides
a kind of time constraint
because once you've planted
enough flowers, you need
to get to the exit
before he finds those flowers
and starts eating them.
And you can also jump
on the runkins
and they'll pop out any seeds
from flowers that they've eaten.
Bridge: Yeah, I think everyone
was struck by, you know,
once you started playing it,
you actually--
you start getting addicted
very quickly.
Easily blow an hour
even though
that there are only
three levels right now,
but we're really
looking forward
to seeing it built up
in the future.
So maybe, Bob, maybe you
can talk about a little bit
sort of what the biggest--
What recommendations
do you have for people
that are getting started
with the API?
And, you know, maybe both what
you've liked best
about working with the API
and maybe the things
that you found
the hardest as well.
Paradiso: Sure.
Okay.
To speak a little bit to that
and go off something
you mentioned,
yeah, definitely start simple
just so that,
you know, you got some stuff
on the screen.
I like to do that whenever I'm
starting with new technology.
The first cut
of the game just had--
What was it?
There was a sample crate
you had
with your model viewer
and the first level
was nothing but--
The ground was built
out of crates
and you were a little crate
that would jump on those.
And he'd run around,
and that was really good,
because I was able
to hand that off
to a guy to start tweaking
physics parameters and stuff,
and as soon as that started
to come together,
the animation guy could,
you know, start getting
jump animations, stuff like
that, that kind of matched
that kind of physics motion.
I really--
I enjoy doing 3-D work.
And I do enjoy
platformers a lot,
so this was a great project
to be working on.
I think the thing that was
challenging for me--
one thing that was challenging
was I was new
to JavaScript doing this,
so that was
a big thing to learn.
But that came together,
and as far as...
Well, it was just really helpful
to have a dialogue
between us and Google
as things were coming up.
Working that stuff out.
I don't know.
Bridge: Any tips or tricks
that you found?
Well, I mean other
than prototyping.
I think that's
a great sort of lesson.
Paradiso: Prototyping's
a good thing.
There's JavaScript stuff
I'm sure you guys know.
Like, for example, like,
you know, garbage collection.
That was a big thing
in the game optimizing
towards the end
to get it working,
so, you know,
making sure you don't
allocate a lot of stuff
while the game's running.
And also there was...
Yeah, I think--
Yeah.
Just kind of doing
performance stuff
as you're working
on the game is important
to kind of see
how much you can throw in.
But it took a lot more
than we--
It took a lot of stuff
that we were surprised.
It took it really well.
Bridge: Okay, great.
And actually--
So Crazy Pixel's working
on another project
and has been producing art
for a terror defense game.
This one hasn't
buffered either.
But maybe you can talk
a little bit about that
since you've had
development expertise
with O3D as well,
you know?
What you've liked most and what
you found the hardest
in terms of working
with the API.
McRae: Sure, yeah, okay.
So the Island demo
was easy for us,
'cause we're primarily
an art studio
specializing
in next-gen graphics.
So that really
came natural to us.
When we started approaching
this project,
which is
a tower defense game,
we wanted to really--
On the art side,
we wanted to specifically use
what's available stock in O3D.
So, you know,
the Island demo
had a lot of custom shaders
that were handwritten
in JavaScript after export.
And our approach on this one
is to, you know--
to act as more
of a typical end user
and export the characters,
objects, that kind of thing,
without doing
any custom scripting
of the materials afterwards.
And we're finding it
to be very forgiving
for sort of a "game engine,"
quote, end quote.
We're able to skin
the characters
using the skin modifier
in 3D Studio MAX
to any kind of custom
bone rig that we have.
And, you know,
typically in a game engine
you could only use, like,
two or three-bone weighting
and, you know, you wind up
exporting your object
and it turns into,
like, spaghetti
or, you know, the vertex rate
gets all messed up.
And we haven't found any
problems like that whatsoever
with O3D.
So I use the word "forgiving,"
you know,
when that kind of thing
just kind of happens
and it just works great,
you know, first round.
Materials.
Everything comes through
with specularity,
you know,
which is great.
The falloff
and the glossiness
and all
the kind of parameters
inside of a standard
MAX material
are all, you know,
retained and exported.
The diffuse map, you just
stick it in that map channel.
The normal map, you stick
in that map channel.
Specular map, you know?
Translucency.
Even multi subobjects,
you know, all work.
So on the material
and the modeling side,
and even animation, everything
has been coming over great.
The first tool
that we needed to make--
because you do need
to make tools
when you're creating
sort of a game--
is for the artist,
a model viewer.
And it was a luxury
to go to the API site
and just kind of grab from all
these different, you know,
samples and piece together
what we wanted.
'Cause we knew we wanted
to be able to load an object,
load an animation,
see what the frame rate is,
be able to rotate
around the object
so that the artists
know what to do
to get it to look
how they want it to.
And so that was
the first tool we made.
It only took three days
and, you know,
after that we were able
to just go full sprint
on all of our characters
and objects
for the tower defense game.
And then the other side,
of course, is the programming.
You know, like I said,
we're mostly an art house,
so, you know, when we
approached the programming--
You know, we're used to--
We also use Torque game builder
and that kind of thing
for our own internal
game development.
And so we're used
to scripting languages
and that kind of thing.
And there was
a little bit of a ramp up
for us for the JavaScripting.
The fact that, you know,
everything for the runtime
on the canvas
is all exposed into, you know,
that one, you know,
main instruction
that runs the canvas was
a little new to us.
And something else that we were
kind of scratching our heads on
is the fact that every object
needs to be parented
to a transform and then you
then manipulate that transform
through your own custom
variables as opposed to,
you know, getting and setting,
you know, transform positions.
So some slight differences.
And we actually--
After thinking about it,
the fact that the transforms
are so modular to the objects
is kind of a luxury,
because then you could,
you know, swap, you know,
objects out to different
transforms pretty easily,
and it's actually kind of nice
once you get used to it.
So just a couple
of things that, you know,
were a little new to us,
but, you know,
we're well under way
and I believe
we're gonna have the game done
in about a month and a half,
and it's been a lot of fun
to work on so far.
Paradiso: Sorry, I'm a little
bit new to being onstage,
so I'm a little bit nervous.
I'll probably avoid
eye contact and stuff.
Sorry about that.
But just to speak
to some of that stuff,
that was interesting.
We actually--in some ways
we did it
from a little bit
of a different angle.
For, like, the art side,
we found that
although Maya did export
the settings out
to, you know,
O3D with some fidelity,
that was really good.
We found that--I guess
especially since we had
a separate 3-D artist
from a texture artist,
we found that it was more useful
to externalize the textures
and the normal maps
and all those other settings.
And we had it such that the 3-D
modeler would export it once
and then since all the other
stuff was externalized
in XML files,
the texture artist
could go ahead and tweak that
stuff till he was happy with it,
and that was how we
separated that out.
The transform thing
was interesting too.
That was a little bit new.
When we were doing this
platformer game,
what we wound up doing
was we, you know--
we set up, like,
just a basic class
that was, you know,
just a model,
and he would own a transform
and he would own
his rotations and positions.
And every tick, you know,
the physics would tick by
and it would update
his position and then
we just had a code
that would then push that
into the transform and then O3D
took care of the rest
of rendering that out
to where we needed it.
So, yeah, that was our way
of getting around that stuff.
Bridge: So I have sort of
a general question for you all.
So looking out at the world
of 3-D on the web right now,
there's a lot of excitement.
There's a lot of activity.
So there's Google's O3D.
Mozilla also has its
Canvas 3D technology,
and we're working
on that with them also
in the context of Chronos.
For those of you not familiar
with Canvas 3D,
it's basically direct OpenGL
bindings from the browser.
So it's--
in a contrast to O3D,
it's what's called
an immediate mode API
rather than
a retain mode API.
And if any of you were
at our talk yesterday
or would like to see it,
you can find the videos
that talk more about
the technical details online.
But--
So looking around
at what's sort of happening
on the web right now,
what direction would you
like to see all of this take,
and do you think
what's emerging right now
is what's right
for developers and what
developers really need
from 3-D APIs for the web?
Tinney: Well, I mean,
I think that the direction
I'd most like to see it take is
towards some kind of standard.
I think, you know,
we'd love to see
this technology native
to all of the browsers
or at least
the modern browsers.
And, you know, so we've
been working in Flash
for a long time.
We're a Flash studio
primarily these days.
And we're comfortable
with that plug-in
because it
is propagated so widely.
So that's the real challenge
of any of these technologies.
We love the fact
that we can have
the kind of performance
that we have in this game
and the kind of lighting
and 3-D assets
that we have in this game.
And it opens up a world
of possibilities for us.
And the fact that it's so--
we can so easily access
other web services and connect
into the social graph,
and, you know--that presents
an amazing opportunity.
So then the question is, well,
how can we make sure that
accessing is seamless
for millions and millions
of just average users,
right?
So where we want
to see it go is just
wide distribution of great
content that drives that access.
McRae: Yeah, I kind of see
a bit of a rebirth here
of what happened
when Flash came out,
you know, in 3-D.
So I think it's really exciting.
I remember, you know,
back when Flash came out,
everybody had just amazing
intro Flash videos
on their web sites
and, you know,
that was when we all had,
like, you know,
5k download on our modems
or whatever
and it was just awesome
to see, like, all this motion
and everything happen
on our little modems.
And, you know, nowadays,
you know,
things have progressed so far
in just the last ten years.
You know, now we have this.
I think it's mind-boggling
to think, like,
you know, what could happen
not just in an intro,
you know, sort of video to get
people into your web site,
but what if
the intro video turned
into your web site,
you know?
I just saw
"Terminator: Salvation"
and we've all seen,
you know, these crazy,
awesome movies where, you know,
there's a computer interface
and it's, like, this huge
network in 3-D space
and people are flying to these
different nodes or whatever
and that information's
coming out at you.
What about web sites
like that?
I think that could
be really awesome
aside from the fact that,
you know,
you could do entertaining
applications like games.
So I think there's just
a world of possibilities
available to us.
And the bottleneck I believe
is gonna be just the developers,
you know, us authoring
these applications,
these experiences.
I would love
to see somebody do, like,
a Flash or a Photoshop
sort of a tool
to author within this
so that, you know,
a 3-D artist who doesn't
really understand JavaScript
could, you know,
piece together Java code,
bring in his assets,
adjust lights and materials,
all that kind of stuff within
some kind of a game editor
or authoring tool
or something like that.
I think that
would really open it up
and it'd be an amazing time
to see
what comes from something
like that.
Tinney: So, yeah.
I mean, that actually
reminds me.
We were talking
over dinner last night
and one of the things that--
as we were working on it
and as Bob mentioned,
you know,
we always look
to externalize assets
as much as possible so that
other people on the team
can tweak and adjust those
assets without
taking up Bob's precious time.
So, you know,
we did that with models,
we did that with textures,
and we would love
to see that--something similar
happen with shaders
and we always do it with text
and copy in the game.
So then that started
me thinking,
"Well, if you had
kind of public repositories
of these different types
of assets--"
So you had a public library
of models
and another of textures
and another of shaders
and so on and so forth,
then you could let
really, you know,
independent developers
who don't have a team
with designers and artists--
maybe just an engineer
or maybe just an artist
that's working and pulling,
you know, functional
code modules for different
character behaviors
and world descriptions--
that they could just kind of
be pulling from different
libraries and creating,
you know, doing quick prototypes
of different common game types.
I think that this
is a step in the direction
of making something
like that possible.
Bridge: Great.
Well, with that I actually
wanted to open it up
to the audience to ask any
of us questions about O3D.
How to get started
working with it,
tips and tricks,
anything like that.
man: Did you guys use
the embedded V8 at all?
Paradiso: Actually,
for our game, we didn't.
We're definitely
gonna look into doing that.
We were able to get
pretty good performance
even without doing that.
So, yeah,
it was a short timeline,
so that was
kind of a lower priority
since we were able to get
the frame rates we wanted.
man: Hi.
I have two questions.
One is how do you--
What do you think
about the Canvas 3D
and the O3D
and what will happen to O3D
if Canvas 3D
becomes more popular
or it becomes more
of a standard,
or is one or the other gonna
become one of the standards?
Bridge: Yeah, so I'd say
we're very supportive
of the Canvas 3D work.
We're actively collaborating
with Mozilla
and Apple and Opera
on standardizing
basically what
is Canvas right now
in the context of the Chronos
organization.
And we really want
to see OpenGL bindings
available in browsers.
I think we still
have some concerns
about performance
in some situations.
So particularly in things,
like, you know,
like the beach scene where you
have a lot of different objects,
we're just concerned
about being able
to actually draw all of that
in 16 milliseconds,
as that's basically
what you need to do
if you want to get
a 60 frames per second.
So I think over time,
you know,
since we are collaborating
with Mozilla,
I think we might see over time
that there are
sort of two APIs
that wind up emerging.
And a good analogy
that Matt Papakipos
was using yesterday was that
you'd say of Canvas,
which is an immediate mode,
and SBG,
which is a retain mode API
for doing graphics.
But what we'd like to do since
we are working together
with them is have the two work
seamlessly together
so that if you wanted to,
for example,
set up a huge scene
but then draw, you know,
a foreground that's
animated every frame,
you could do the background
perhaps in retain
and then do the foreground
in an immediate mode API.
man: Okay.
Second part of
my question is--
that has to deal
with performance,
have you done any real tests
of how much data
can you handle in O3D
in terms of loading polygons?
I have a system that previously
was worked on
by people at Stanford
where we have a client
and server environment.
On the server,
we're actually loading millions
and millions of polygons--
like, 100 million polygons--
whereas on the client end,
we load a very low-res.
And we have a sort
of fake animation
where you're able
to rotate the models
and do whatever navigation
you need to,
but then in the end you do get
a high-resolution model.
So what I look to do
is convert my clients
to something like O3D,
because right now
it's running in Java,
or Canvas 3D.
But I'd like
to know how much--
How many polygons
can it handle?
Bridge: Yeah, I'd encourage
you to try.
We haven't done any
actual sort of benchmarking
and seeing how many objects you
can get on the screen.
One of the
tough things, though,
is, I mean,
since it is a PC platform,
we're very dependent
on the hardware
that's running underneath
to some extent.
So it's gonna vary
a lot based on--
based on the individual
user's machine, so...
Yeah, so I'd encourage you
to do some testing.
I don't know if you all
had some experience
in sort of
a mid-range machine,
what you could actually
get on it.
man: More specifically,
I should just go back into--
What can the Ajax and the
JavaScript functions handle?
Not necessarily--
Because I know it goes
to OpenGL,
but I'm assuming there is
a JavaScript limitation
of some sort.
The API has some kind
of limitations
where the browser times out
or they're, you know,
you can't load certain
things in.
Bridge: Well, I mean,
right now,
for getting actual content
into it,
in the plug-in we have
essentially a streaming API
that allows you to pull down
a tarred, gzipped
archive of stuff.
And basically if you've
constructed the archive right,
you can actually also
sort of load it progressively.
But I don't know
that we've seen
any type of specific limit
in terms of time-outs
of amount of content.
I don't know.
Wade?
Tinney: Well, I can give you
the non-engineer's
perspective on it,
because I was asking
the same question
in the beginning.
Like, what's--
You know, 'cause I was involved
in the game design side.
Like, what is the limit?
You know, what are
the constraints
that we're working towards?
And, you know,
the people on the team
patiently explained to me
that it's a difficult
question, you know?
Because, yeah, you can keep
putting crates onto the screen
until the computer crashes
and then you know
how many crates
you can put on the screen,
but once the crates
have different textures
and some crates are,
you know,
crazy tetrahedrons and--
or animating
and you have, you know,
collision detection happening,
you know,
in different machines.
All these things start
to make it very--
It was really
about figuring out
what you want to accomplish.
Getting as close
to that as you can
and then pushing
and pulling
until you find--
until you find the boundaries.
I will say that
I was amazed
at the fact that
we never really hit
that performance barrier
with our game.
And I encourage you
to play it.
We're gonna make
the demo available
on our web site
in the next week or so.
But I have--
I think I have the oldest
computer in the company
for some reason and,
you know,
I think it's a three
or four-year-old ThinkPad
and it runs totally fine
on that.
And, you know,
some of our pre-optimized
Flash applications
chug on my machine.
So I'm pretty happy
about that.
I don't know if you have
anything to add.
Paradiso: Yeah,
that's about right.
I mean, it's like
a running joke.
His laptop is the one
we tested it on
before we put it out
to the world
'cause it's the lowest end
common denominator.
Yeah, just to echo
what you said,
yeah, it's really, like--
at least we found,
from the rendering end,
some of it's like, "What are
you doing with those polys?"
You know, what was
the complication of the shader?
What's the complexity
of the shader you're using?
We hit more
of a bottleneck
with what you're doing
with the JavaScript.
We had to be more careful
with that,
how we were doing our math,
how we were using memory,
and stuff like that than we
did from the rendering end.
But, yeah, we found ways
around all that stuff.
McRae: Yeah, so I worked on
an Xbox game
before we had an Xbox devkit.
And so I have some experience
on, you know,
just how you go about finding
the constraints
and restrictions that
you're dealing with
when you're working on a new
platform such as this.
And, you know, the dust
is eventually gonna settle.
Everything is really
brand new right now,
so there's a lot of, you know,
testing that needs to happen.
You know, for instance,
with Xbox,
we found that the thing
that was the biggest hit
was just the bone counts
on the characters.
And that's why you
eventually saw
games that had,
you know, 50 or so
or 100 characters on screen,
you know,
and then you could approximate
their collisions
by, you know, just putting
big spheres around them
and that kind of thing.
So, you know, we found that
it was bone count
and it was
collision detection
and then, you know,
environment polygons
and that kind of thing started,
you know, seeping in too
along with the amount
of materials that you had.
So I would expect
that same sort of, you know,
pattern to follow here
to some degree.
But you never know.
We might be surprised.
Maybe it handles bones great.
It's just running through
the actual translations
of the bones
is what slows us down
and then we find some kind
of optimization there.
You know, maybe it is polygons
that slows us down.
Maybe it's just the JavaScript
code itself
is what's the slowest thing
that holds everything up.
So it's exciting and I think
it's gonna be
up to the developers
to, you know, find what happens.
man: So what I'm
gathering here--
I was gonna ask a question
similar to that.
Did you find it was more
the JavaScript side
or did you find it was
the underneath side?
I'm gathering it's
the JavaScript side.
So what I did once
just to play with it
was I took out--
I had the discreet card
look and see
what frames per second
I was getting.
Ripped out
the discreet card and saw
what the CPU would do
with it.
It was probably about
a 15 to 20 frames per second
difference between the two
from the hardware and software.
The other thing that
I thought was interesting
was that
the CPU jumped up 40%.
But what you're telling me
is it's a little bit different--
that it requires
more processing capabilities
from the JS side is where you
guys ran into bottlenecks.
So what my question is is are
you guys gonna characterize
some of the performance
that you have,
or is there ways
to characterize it
so that we know exactly,
you know, what we can do
from both ends--
either the native side,
which is, you know,
the DirectX or OpenGL
versus the JavaScript--and see
where the bottlenecks are?
Bridge: I would say I'm not sure
to what extent
we will characterize it fully.
I think one of the things that
is very interesting to us
is basically creating a suite
of benchmarks
of what the common
operations are that you have
in a 3-D application--
so anything from sorting
to collision detections
in physics and things like that.
Because we found
over and over again
with browsers in general that
the second you make
a benchmark, particularly
a JavaScript benchmark,
everyone jumps on it
and tries to make it faster.
So I think something like
that will be a good guide
also in terms of figuring
out applications,
but will really provide a way
for all the browsers
to improve the JavaScript
performance,
which, you know,
is increasing
at blinding speed right now.
Paradiso: And another thing
just related to that, quick,
is, like, sometimes there's
workarounds
that the plug-in gives you.
Like, sometimes you'll be doing
a lot of matrix math,
which doing it in JavaScript,
you know,
it's a little bit slower than
you'd like it to be sometimes.
But the plug-in does allow
you to do
some matrix math within it.
So when I switched
to doing that,
in some cases that of course
sped up things a lot.
So you just got to, you know,
look around
and you can find ways
around it.
man: Hi.
I'm a web application
developer.
So...well, my question is
do you see a way
in which O3D could
find a spot
in web applications
beside games?
I mean, if you had
to redesign a Gmail
or Basecamp or whatever,
or YouTube,
in which way would
you use O3D, like,
to make the application
richer?
Tinney: Well--
Bridge: Go ahead.
Tinney: There's a couple guys
sitting right behind you
actually that could probably--
You should find them after.
Guys to your other side.
One of the sandbox demos
was a team from ABC-Disney
and they had done
a kind of experimental
O3D interface to do a catalogue
of their video content.
So I think there's
a ton of possibilities.
And for me, the interesting
thing is, you know,
I think we probably read
about the fact
that humans can...understand
and wrap their head
around 3-D--full 3-D spatially
positioned objects--
quicker than 2-D.
You know, like, your house.
You know where everything
is in your house
and that's a lot
of different objects.
So I think there's a huge
opportunity there
to explore more
experimental interfaces
that take advantage of that
just cognitive fact.
Bridge: So I think
some ideas that we have,
I think that there's a lot
of potential,
as Wade was saying,
in data visualization stuff
in terms of representing
lots of data.
Whether it's actually
representing the location
of an object in the 3-D space,
or interfaces,
you know, maybe a photo browser
or things like that
that allow you to flip through
photos very fluidly.
I think there's also
a lot of applications
that you could think about
in terms of any product
that has a physical component.
So we have a sample
on our site
which allows you to take,
you know, furniture
from a sidebar and drag it
into a scene, move it around.
So you can imagine
shopping for, you know,
for furniture or other products
that way.
I think what's going
to need to happen
in order for that
kind of content to be created
is O3D is still
very low level.
We're probably going to need
some even higher level
JavaScript APIs in order
to really make it easy
for people to do that--
things like if you think
about analogies
of, like, jQuery or MooTools
and all of those sorts of
JavaScript frameworks
that make it easy
to do a lot of the common,
you know,
web 2.0 kind of effects
and things like that.
So if you have ideas
and 3-D experience,
I would encourage you
to build something like that
and send it around 'cause we're
just dying to see that happen.
[man speaking indistinctly]
The question was how about
porting Google Earth to it?
That's something that
we'd certainly like to see,
but we don't have any
plans to announce right now.
man: Yeah, I'm curious
about the data format
for the art assets.
Like, did you use a standard
one like COLLADA
or some other format?
And then also,
after it was in that format,
did you have to compress it
into a binary
for when you had it, like,
running in the game,
or was it you could just leave
it, like, flat?
Bridge: We get
that question a lot.
Actually, we don't have any
native data format in O3D.
Basically what we've provided
is a binary
that you run offline
that lets you take COLLADA
and convert it to
a compressed JSON file,
and then we provided a
corresponding JavaScript file
that when you want
to unpack that archive
in your application,
you bring in that JavaScript
file and essentially run it
to recreate the content
that you had created.
But it's not actually
a data format in that
what we've provided is really
just a sample implementation,
so if you had content
that you wanted
to include that was unique
to your application,
you could take our converter,
which is open source,
and modify it to include other
information in the archive
and you could provide your
own corresponding
JavaScript library so that
the application developer
has total flexibility
in terms of file format
and what content to include.
man: 'Cause that's, like,
on the OpenGL side.
But, like, for you guys,
for your game,
like, you came from Maya
or 3D Studio MAX,
so, like, obviously it's not
gonna read in a MAX file
or a bip or, like--
how--like--what were--
McRae: Yeah, I think a less
technical,
I guess, answer
for you would be, yes.
You export a COLLADA file.
We use COLLADA Nextgen.
It's a special, I guess,
COLLADA exporter.
It's free.
And so you export as that.
You take the d-a-e file and
you drag it over
a tool that Google has made
that sort of packages
everything up.
So the COLLADA file,
you know,
stores paths and everything
to all your textures
and all that, you know,
kind of stuff,
and then when you condition
it with the tool
that Google supplies,
it makes a t-g-z file,
I believe,
which is essentially
like some kind of
an archive file
that has everything
all in it.
So it's got your mesh data,
it's got all your textures,
got your material information,
all that great stuff.
It's then all packaged in there
and then all you got to do
if you want to see it
in the, you know,
in the O3D canvas is you just,
you know, load that object,
that package, and there it is.
man: So is that the open format
that you provide,
like, an example of?
How it's zipped up
and run through
the OpenGL libraries or--
Bridge: Yeah, exactly.
We provided essentially
a sample
that does it for COLLADA,
but the way
that we've implemented it
and the level
at which it's exposed
is anyone could build
whatever they wanted
on top of it.
So if you wanted
to natively support
something like FBX, you could
build something to do that
or whatever format
you wanted to do.
man: Okay.
Bridge: Yeah, really we were
trying to, again,
provide the plumbing at sort
of the similar level
as OpenGL or DirectX would
and not try and make
any assumptions about
what the developer
is trying to do with it
so that, you know,
we could define
a file format maybe
that was specific for games or
specific for photos
or things like that, but we want
to enable all of those things
and not just one.
man: Hi.
I'm just curious.
You know, as you continue
to develop O3D
and you get closer to moving--
you know, people using ANSYS,
like Android ANSYS
for browsing the web.
How does O3 play
in the mobile space,
considering that right now
the current implementation
is heavily dependent on,
like, the OpenGL--
OpenGL ES 2.0 or 1.0
and so forth.
Bridge: So I think basically
the level that we shot for
was we think
that program will--
Graphics is basically
what's going to--
It's basically the future
of where graphics is going,
so that's--
We chose to support that
and that only right now.
I think what you're
alluding to is that
some of the handsets
on the market today
don't actually support
all those capabilities.
Really what we're very
interested in supplying O3D
and 3-D graphics
for the web capability
is for mobile handsets
as well.
We're hoping that
that Moore's Law
and sort of how quickly people
replace handsets
will help us through that
in that
basically if all of the handsets
that are being produced
today and that are coming
to market
will support OpenGL ES 2.0,
which provides
the functionality or a similar
set of functionality
as we require with our API.
So we're betting
on the future a little bit,
but it's definitely something
that we want to look at.
man: I'm gonna
jump in one more time.
Have you thought
about encryption?
Data encryption
or anything like that?
Bridge: So we don't provide
any encryption
or DRM type of solution.
It's a question
that we get a lot
from content developers.
Our main suggestion
in that regard
is that if you're really
concerned
about protecting
at least your code,
you can use JavaScript
obfuscation, compilation
in order to do a lot of that.
man: I'm thinking more
in terms of the 3-D data
rather than the code itself.
Bridge: The 3-D data,
we don't provide
any support for encryption.
So maybe all
of you can talk about
what your thoughts
were about that.
But what we found in talking
to developers
is that they're more concerned
with protecting
the actual code
and their shaders
rather than protecting
the assets,
since most games
that you buy today,
you know,
if you really want to,
you can unpack
all the assets.
Then it really becomes sort
of a legal issue
of enforcing the IP
in that respect.
But I don't know if you have
other thoughts on that there.
Paradiso: We had a thought.
We did think about the code
and the shaders,
doing obfuscation,
and stuff like that.
As far as the 3-D assets,
I have a question for you.
Since we do have access to the
importer and all that stuff,
we could write our own
encryption-decryption stuff,
you know, right within the--
right within
the game code itself.
So you could maybe roll your own
at that point.
That may work out for you.
Bridge: Sure.
That's a great idea.
Any other questions?
Tinney: Perfect clarity.
We've reached perfect clarity
in all things.
Bridge: Right, exactly.
Everyone knows what O3D is
and how to use it.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Sorry?
Could you use the--
So the--
Yeah, so the question is do we
have a lot of sample code?
And the answer is, yes,
we have a ton of sample codes.
So I think we have over
40 samples at this point
and we're adding
to it all the time.
It's code.google.com/apis/o3d.
So if you go there,
you can browse it,
and if you have
the plug-in installed,
then you can view
a lot of things,
including the Beach demo
and the demo that we actually--
that Greg showed off yesterday,
we'll also be posting.
Another neat thing is since O3D
is completely open source,
all of the samples
and the assets
to the samples and all
of that is also open source.
So if you want
to create a mash-up
of a robot dancing on an island
or something like that,
you can certainly
go ahead and do that.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Kung fu movie.
Oh, okay.
Definitely.
Tinney: Also I just wanted
to mention
we're gonna be posting over
the next couple weeks
a bunch of kind of behind
the scenes information
and images from our process of
working on it
over those five weeks and
looking forward
to connecting with people.
And if people
have questions for us,
then we're happy
to answer them.
And we'd love to get
a community of developers
going around it.
Bridge: Awesome, so if no one
has any other questions,
thanks a lot and I think
we'll stick around here
if there's anything you didn't
want to ask on the mic.
Thank you.